[Music]  [Music]  the world goes the skeleton was coming  that really caught my imagination and  inspired me Rupert is really a visionary  and has completely created a mnemonic  you the manga - the anime fan but has  put his thumb prints all over this  project so I guess I fell that we took  them to me what would the most iconic  pieces and built the rest the universe  narrative lead assisted the great thing  about the film vision is that every  scene you go to somewhere different it's  in a gret row future in a way where  everyone been harmed do you see the  world differently not the future that we  imagined to be kind of pristine and  personality with cities built upon city  we have 80 cars and 19 machine gun very  much a dull Junt idea of what the future  could be because of the power of wall  Shiro creates original I feel we're just  another part of the legacy would go  through shelter  you